>>I was instructor at the
South Marks High School.
And we did everything from
backpacking trips to ropes courses
in the riggings of tall
ships in the harbor.
Then began to do urban exploration.
It was an attempt to bring
the methodology and philosophy
of Outward Bound into the inner city,
and into classrooms
for the first time.
So it really is out
of the work that kind
of Expeditionary Learning was
designed, and came to life.
>>Oh, yeah, you're right.
>>Susan: So we designed
this expedition where teams
of students interviewed
people who have struggled
with housing and homelessness.
Because the work that we
do, it has to be compelling,
and it has to be looking
at the real world.
We're called Expeditionary
Learning for a reason.
You know, the classic
expedition, you're out with a group
of people trying to climb a mountain.
And the goal is real.
And you're driven towards it.
You all want to get there, because
you know that there will be a sense
of accomplishment in the end.
And all of the consequences
along the way are real.
[laughs] It starts to rain.
Like that happens.
Your computer dies!
That happens, you know,
these things go on.
You know, these things go on.
But you're committed to
this end objective together.
So the relationships
become important,
and the connections become important.
And when you offer someone
the opportunity to engage
in something real, and push
them and challenge them
to do things they never
thought they could possibly do,
there is nothing more exhilarating.
>>Okay, how long have
you each been homeless?
>>I've been in and out of the
shelters on and off like 22 years.
>>So how did that affect you?
>>Because of the way
you have to live,
and the fact that you
may not be proud of it,
wears on your self-esteem, no
matter how good your self-esteem is.
It's going to be--
it's very draining.
>>I want my students to walk out of
my classroom skilled, knowledgeable,
capable, and ready to tackle the
problems of their lives in the world.
But I believe that in
order to achieve that,
you have to feel like you belong.
And you have to feel comfortable
enough to be who you are.
Because none of us are
capable of learning
when we're closed off,
and when we're fearful.
>>Thank you so much.
>>Woman: Thank you.
>>Susan: I think that's
one of the reasons
that we have the dropout
rates that we have in schools,
is that we have these large
monolithic places where people walk
through the halls anonymously.
And no one notices whether
they're there or not.
Why would you go someplace where you
don't know whether someone's going
to notice whether you're
there or not?
But I get up in the
morning and show up,
because I know my friends
are going to be there.
My colleagues are my friends.
And I'm going to get to say, "Hello!"
Right? I'm going to talk about the
weekend before we get into the work.
>>So I've got groups
arranged around the laptops.
You'll be meeting those groups
and presenting these things.
So they must ...
>>Susan: So we've got to build
a community in our classroom.
We have to build a
community in our school.
We have to create a space where
students feel like their whole self,
and everything about them matters.
I challenge my students far more
than I would if I were in a place
where we didn't know each other.
>>Writing process standard, and
quality of writing standard.
I need to see your revisions and
all those drafts stapled together.
>>Derek: Susan is an
intellectual, but she brings
as much heart as head to her game.
And she convinces kids
that if their--
if they're not passionate about
what they're doing, then they need
to dig deeper and find what
they are passionate about.
Because once they're passionate,
she knows that intellectual
engine is going to be catalyzed,
and they're doing to do great things
that they didn't think they could do,
and which will motivate
them to do the next thing.
>>I want you guys to see
something, because it's going
to give you a taste, and
it's going to inspire us,
and then you're going
to work so hard!
>>She gets the adrenaline rush out
of kids that is typically only gotten
from the football coach
or the drama teacher.
Because they're fired up
about what they're studying,
and what they're going to
present and share with the world.
>>So you got to make
some of those decisions.
Okay.
>>Ms. McCray?
I love her, quite -- just aside
from being a great English teacher,
it's just she's the kind of teacher
that you go to with whatever.
She's always there for you.
Always full of life.
If you're going to teach
Expeditionary Learning,
you have to have a
certain spark in you.
And she just has so much of that.
So.
>>Go to "Share."
Try "Share."
No? Huh. Are you in
the slideshow part?
Yeah, I'm on it.
>>It's really hard work.
It's grueling, and it's
demoralizing, because you see the kid
that you're not reaching.
And you see there's
several young people
that are slipping through the cracks.
Or you feel like it's not happening.
The curriculum that you
spent hours planning,
the lesson that you designed,
and you spent all this
time around falls flat.
You know? It happens to
all of us, all the time.
And I think the key to sustaining
yourself in teaching is to be able
to know that that is a reality.
And that's a fact of the profession.
And to know you got to get up
the next morning and try again.
[laughs]
>>For more information on what works
in public education
go to edutopia.org